je vous remercie par avance d'avoir
répondu présent à notre invitation
conjointe des deux délégations la
délégation aux outre-mer et la
délégation aux droits des femmes du
Sénat avec le président Stéphane Artano
et les rapporteurs nous sommes très
heureux de vous accueillir cet
après-midi au Sénat pour vous rendre
compte d'un travail qui nous a
occupé presque 6 mois avec nos deux
délégations conjointes pour travailler
sur la parentalité dans les territoires
d'outre-mer un sujet finalement
d'actualité puisqu'on en parle beaucoup
avec les événements et l'actualité
récente dans l'Hexagone par exemple le
titre du rapport qui avait fait qui
vient d'être voté à l'unanimité en
réunion de nos deux délégations soutient
à la parentalité agir pour toutes les
familles des Outre-mer donc de
délégation délégation droit des femmes
délégation aux outre-mer 4 rapporteurs
victoires jasmin pour la Guadeloupe
belles achats qui étaient territoires un
petit peu moins
ultramarins l'est de la France et le
président Stéphane Artano pour
saint-pierre-et-miquel Miquelon pardon
nous avons auditionné quelques 120
personnes pendant ces 5 6 mois nous nous
sommes déplacés hélas je dirais que dans
celles un seul territoire mais trois
îles quand même la Guadeloupe
Saint-Martin et Saint-Barth où nous
avons été accueillis par les sénatrices
du cru local à la fois
victoire jasmin évidemment puisqu'elle
était rapporteur elle faisait partie du
déplacement mais également Micheline
Jacques pour Saint-Barth et Annick
jacquemais pour Annick Annick Petrus
Annick siège dans mon groupe Annick
Pétrus pour Saint-Martin excusez-moi
donc l'objectif c'est bien entendu à la
fois de dresser les constats qui vont
nous amener qui nous ont amenés à faire
un certain nombre de recommandations va
recommandations et dans les constats
évidemment ce qu'on a mis en exergue
c'est essentiellement des familles en
situation de précarité et de
vulnérabilité avec des modèles familiaux
liés à finalement l'histoire la culture
Nassima d'un Dark et au premier rang et
qui représente la réunion nous a fait
part aussi de l'histoire et l'impact des
phénomènes culturels du coup avec
l'esclavage aussi qui a pu faire que on
se retrouve aujourd'hui avec des des
familles monoparentales qui sont
monoparentales dès le début c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a pas une séparation c'est que
dès le début ce sont des familles
monoparentales bien souvent avec des
femmes à la tête et l'absence des pères
mais notre collègue rapporteur
elsachalke vous en parlera tout à
l'heure donc l'idée évidemment à
traverser ces travaux mieux connaître
les particularités des territoires
c'est bien dommage
si elle est la seule c'est bien bon
c'est comme c'est l'introduction c'est
pas très grave
qui êtes-vous madame
j'arrête ou je continue à s'étend
c'était une répétition
comment
je continue très bien donc
l'idée c'est évidemment de d'avoir une
meilleure connaissance
des spécificités des des territoires
connaître pour adapter les politiques
connaître pour différencier et forcément
la première recommandation que nous
faisons c'est généraliser les obser les
observatoires à la parentalité à l'image
de ce qui existe à la réunion nous avons
mis en exergue bien entendu aussi la
prévalence des familles en situation de
précarité économique de vulnérabilité
sociale et ce qui rend évidemment très
complexe
l'exercice de la parentalité un chiffre
ou plusieurs chiffres mais
sur le taux de pauvreté le taux de
pauvreté pour la Martinique c'est 78%
pour Mayotte c'est 77% et pour
l'Hexagone c'est 15% donc forcément on
comprend que l'ex de la parentalité et
beaucoup plus difficile donc les
politiques familiales on a pu le
constater avec des des misants des mises
en place parfois à géométrie variable
avec des caves des PMI qui remplissent
plus ou moins leur mission et mes
collègues rapporteurs
vous exposeront ces situations ce qu'on
peut dire par rapport aux prestations
sociales et familiales deux tiers des
habitants des dromes perçoivent ces
prestations sociales ou familiales ce
qui est considérable alors avec des
différences et notamment des différences
qui ont été fléchées à Mayotte avec
si je m'entends en double ça va ça va
être compliqué mais on a la clim alors
on se satisfait de tout même du son
aujourd'hui donc des prestations qui
sont quasiment à l'identique dans tous
les territoires Drom historique et dans
l'Hexagone à deux exceptions près le
versement des allocations familiales dès
le premier enfant et les conditions
d'octroi du complément familial donc à
Mayotte des conditions un peu
différentes c'est pour ça que notre
deuxième recommandation et bien elle
demande à ce qui est une étude
comparative des incidences budgétaires
et socio-économiques sur les familles
des différents systèmes existants pour
avant d'aller plus loin avant de prendre
de faire des propositions d'avoir un
vrai état des lieux de la situation dans
ce territoire de Mayotte on a mis en
exergue aussi les taux d'illettrisme et
d'électronisme qui rendent également
plus difficile l'exercice de la
parentalité avec des recommandations 3
et 5 sur des propositions pour avancer
sur ces sujets il est surprenant de voir
que dans certains territoires les aussi
les parents ne parlant pas la langue
peuvent difficilement accéder aux
différents outils des politiques
publiques donc je vais laisser la parole
à elsacha qui ont répondra bien sûr une
fois que les quatre rapports les
rapporteurs se seront exprimés aux
questions s'il y en a je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente bonjour à
toutes et tous alors à mon tour
d'intervenir sur un autre volet qui est
les spécificités des structures
familiales et parentales ultramarine
puisque nous avons mis en exergue trois
traits qui nous semblent
particulièrement marquants d'une part la
place centrale des femmes et des mers et
l'absence en miroir des pères
deuxièmement la fréquence des grossesses
précoces et troisièmement le rôle des
familles élargies donc je vais revenir
sur la première caractéristique qui est
la place centrale des mers elle se
traduit aujourd'hui par une forte
prévalence de la monoparentalité tout
particulièrement aux Antilles et en
Guyane où les familles monoparentales
représentent la moitié des familles avec
enfants soit deux fois plus que dans
l'Hexagone donc il s'agit en pratique de
mer seule qui cumulent comme l'a dit
notre présidente des facteurs de
vulnérabilité elles plus précaire que
les autres parents moins souvent en
emploi plus souvent sur des emplois qui
sont faiblement rémunérés et leurs
conditions de vie sont plus difficiles
les conditions d'entrée dans la
monoparentalité sont elles aussi assez
singulières puisque la monoparentalité
ne fait pas suite à une séparation comme
c'est le majoritairement le cas dans
l'Hexagone mais elle débute dès la
naissance de l'enfant et se poursuit
pendant toute son enfance et un chiffre
qui nous a particulièrement marquée aux
Antilles comme en Guyane deux tiers des
enfants ne sont pas reconnus par leur
père à la naissance alors ce phénomène
évidemment interroge inévitablement sur
la place des pères sur la robe sens
depuis la naissance mais tout au long de
la vie de l'enfant sur la question
également et les conséquences
financières comme éducatif et on voit
bien que
justement il ne les parents les pères et
les mers ne semblent pas y trouver
d'intérêt voire redoute la
reconnaissance juridique des enfants par
leur père ils voient dans l'absence de
reconnaissance d'une stratégie de survie
économique en lien avec le versement des
prestations familiales donc nous
appelons et c'est notre recommandation
numéro 14 à reconsidérer la place du
père au sein des politiques familiales à
la fois en luttant contre les idées
reçues relatives aux effets de sur le
bénéfice des prestations familiales
d'une reconnaissance légale par le père
mais également en associant davantage
les pairs au dispositif de soutien à la
parentalité plus globalement nous
estimons nécessaires de mieux
sensibiliser aux enjeux et aux
responsabilités de la parentalité afin
là aussi de mieux aider de mieux
accompagner les parents dans leur rôle
qu'on rappelle être les premiers
éducateurs de l'enfant le deuxième fait
marquant comme je vous le disais c'est
la question et la fréquence des
grossesses précoces alors soit en
conséquence des recours à l'IVG plus
nombreux dans les outre-mer mais
également des maternités précoces qui
restent nombreuses notamment en Guyane
et à Mayotte avec un chiffre assez
éclairant puisque 10% des naissances
enfin pour 10% des naissances la mer a
moins de 20 ans et les facteurs qui
l'expliquent sont multiples il semble
que la maternité soit pour des jeunes
femmes précaires un moyen d'acquérir un
statut mais également des aides et de
gagner leur autonomie par rapport à leur
famille et ça se fait généralement
effectivement au moment de la naissance
de leur enfant c'est pourquoi nous
recommandations c'est les
recommandations 6 et 7 sont ciblesses
sur cette problématique vous le savez la
loi prévoit trois séances annuelles
d'éducation à la vie affective et
sexuelle dans les scolaire sur
l'ensemble du territoire français mais
malheureusement ces séances ne sont
quasiment pas dispensées aujourd'hui et
il nous semble primordial de veiller à
leur mise en oeuvre et de développer à
la fois la prévention mais également
l'accompagnement des grossesses précoces
notamment parce que c'est également une
des conséquences afin de lutter contre
le décrochage scolaire nous recommandons
également de conforter les dispositifs
permettant aux jeunes maires de
concilier leur vie familiale et
notamment le Service Militaire Adapté
donc le SMA dont on sait à quel point il
représente un atout pour nos jeunes des
outre-mer et c'est un outil qui on a pu
le constater a fait ses preuves et qui
ne gagneraient qu'à être renforcée enfin
à la troisième spécificité que nous
avons souhaité mettre en avant dans ce
constat parce que c'est aussi la force
et la richesse de ce rapport de pouvoir
dresser un constat sur cette thématique
essentielle de la parentalité c'est la
question de la famille élargie et des
sol solidarité intergénérationnelle on
le voit c'est solidarités
traditionnelles s'atténue sous l'effet
de migration interne comme externe et de
la progression du mode de vie occidental
contemporain qui diversifie notamment
les modèles familiaux cependant ces
solidarités notamment ces solidarités
intergénérationnelles demeurent
importantes elles sont importantes d'une
part sur le plan financier mais
également sur la question de l'éducation
des enfants et de la transmission des
valeurs et des savoirs et nous sommes
convaincus tous les quatre tous les
rapporteurs à quel point cette
solidarité est une véritable richesse
sur laquelle nos politiques familiales
devraient davantage s'appuyer nous avons
également fait un focus sur les
pratiques de circulation d'enfant et
d'adoption coutumière au sein des
familles élargies en Nouvelle-Calédonie
et également en Polynésie française et
c'est notre recommandation numéro 10 qui
entend sécuriser ces pratiques je vais
désormais laisser la parole à Victoire
jasmin pour justement nous développer
les recommandations concernant le
service de proximité aux familles
merci beaucoup je vous remercie de nous
avoir pris vraiment au sérieux parce que
nous travaillons
de choses très sérieuses concernant les
autres donc
sénatrice de Guadeloupe membre de Dieu
délégations je suis vraiment très
heureuse de partager ce travail qui je
pense
portera ses fruits à travers les
différentes recommandations que nous
allons vous proposer
cet axe de notre rapport ce troisième
axe souligne l'importance de
l'environnement favorable à la
parentalité cela passe par plus de
services de proximité pour faciliter la
vie des parents notre constat et qu'il
faut les développer et les renforcer
pour que les politiques de soutien à la
parentalité soit mieux adapté aux
spécificités
ultramarines plus encore que dans
d'autres territoires la démarche d'aller
vers l'hiver les parents et les espaces
s'impose dans les outre-mer plusieurs
outils existent déjà nous avons eu un
certain nombre d'exemples notamment à la
Réunion ce qui se fait déjà en Guyane
donc nous voulons vraiment poursuivre et
aller vers les parents
parce que c'est nécessaire les caisses
d'allocations familiales en particulier
joue un rôle essentiel ils ont développé
des formats d'accueil spécifique des
rendez-vous des droits des connexions en
visio de l'assistance informatique pour
aider les allocataires à réaliser leurs
démarches administratives vous trouverez
vous trouverez dans le rapport un
tableau avec de nombreux exemples les
caps s'appuient sur le développement
d'une large réseau de partenaires il
faut également penser au service mis en
place par les espaces en service les
centres communaux d'action sociale et
les partenaires les partenariats avec
les mairies
notre recommandation numéro 4 consiste à
consolider la présence des cafés donc
notamment au travers du réseau des
maisons France service et dans les
maternités pour faciliter l'ouverture
des doigts et développer des guichets
uniques sur le modèle des maisons des
1000 premiers jours près d'entrée
aisément identifiable pour les parents
et les familles
notre recommandation numéro 8 est de
faire aussi du futur service public de
la petite enfance une opportunité pour
rattraper le retard des Outre-mer en
matière de mode de garde en ce qui
concerne l'offre d'accueil en dehors du
temps scolaire nous avons recensé un
certain nombre de difficultés le manque
de personnel qualifié le manque de
moyens des communes ou encore les
difficultés financières des parents
pourtant garantir un meilleur accueil
pour les enfants au-delà du temps
scolaire sur tout le territoire est un
véritable enjeu d'égalité
l'égalité des chances pour les enfants
et une insertion professionnelle pour
les parents nous présentons dans ce
rapport plusieurs pistes d'amélioration
notamment remédier au manque de
personnels qualifiés et promouvoir la
formation d'éducateur accroître l'offre
de colo apprenant par exemple dans tous
les territoires du tramarins en
encourageant le développement des
partenariats avec des structures agrées
pour longer le complément de libre choix
du mode de garde au-delà de 6 ans de
l'enfant afin de faciliter l'accès de
tous les enfants et les adolescents
alors périscolaire développer les
dispositifs multiparentaux par exemple
dans toutes les communes et en Polynésie
il y a évidemment une situation qu'il
faudrait encourager
il est donc essentiel de développer
l'ensemble de ces dispositifs afin
d'offrir aux parents un lieu de partage
d'expérience et d'échanges avec des
professionnels de l'éducation dans une
approche globale et non stigmatisante de
la parentalité notre recommandation
numéro 9 est donc de renforcer l'accueil
collectif des enfants en dehors du temps
périscolaire du temps scolaire avant de
passer la parole au président alternaux
pour présenter le dernier axe je tiens à
souligner l'importance de créer cet
environnement général favorable aux
enfants et à la parentalité ces actions
soutient financiers via les prestations
familiales proximité de la cave solution
de garde dès la petite enfance tant
périscolaire facilite le déploiement de
politique de soutien à la parentalité
proprement dite
monsieur le président Stéphane Artano je
vous passe la parole pour la suite de
nos travaux merci beaucoup merci à vous
tous
bien bonsoir à tous et à tous je vais
vous parler des politiques de soutien à
la parentalité ce qu'on peut dire en
outre-mer c'est qu'il y a globalement
indépoiement partiel voire inégale des
politiques de soutien il y a une
stratégie nationale évidemment qui a
tracé une feuille de route entre
2018-2022 et avec un axe transversal la
parentalité en outre-mer et le bilan
pour le moins qu'on puisse dire est
assez mitigé puisque et clairement
insuffisant ce qui concerne Mayotte et
la Guyane par exemple et même
Saint-Martin il en va de même programme
dit des 1000 premiers jours qui a été
lancé en 2020 et qui cible
particulièrement la petite enfance
programme qui ne comporte pas réellement
de voler outre-mer alors que des
spécificités et des réalités locales
l'exigence le maillage territorial pour
le succès les politiques de parentalité
est évidemment essentielle selon le
ministère des Outre-mer ce qu'on appelle
le panier de service et je ne rentre pas
ici dans le détail si on fait le bilan
en outre-mer il est de 100% à la
Martinique et à la Réunion il y a de 50%
en Guadeloupe 25% en Guyane et Mayotte
on n'a pas les chiffres donc autant vous
dire entre la Guyane et Mayotte le
constat est quand même assez accablant
sur le retard majeur qui a été pris sur
le déploiement de ce panier et qui sont
pourtant les deux territoires français
je dis bien français les plus jeunes de
notre pays en matière de médiation
familiale tous les départements sauf
Mayotte disposent d'un service pour
autant inéquitablement ou inégalement
constitué puisque par exemple en Guyane
il n'y a qu'un seul et TP pour un
territoire grand comme le Portugal donc
ça vous laisse juste imaginer la
performance que même la meilleure
volonté du monde de l'agent en question
peut amener et donc nous recommandations
11 et 15 font évidemment de
l'accélération du déploiement des
politiques notamment des 1000 premiers
jours un axe important de notre point de
vue on a constaté également sur le volet
santé et ça a été rappelé par la
présidente billon un retard assez
inacceptable il faut bien le dire quand
même en matière de PMI qui relève de la
compétence de certains départements ça a
été pointé en Guadeloupe et
particulièrement à Mayotte ou des
successifs ont déjà démontré les
carences de la PMI notamment sur ce
territoire et pour nous il convient
évidemment de traiter en priorité ces
aspects et il existe notamment en
matière de santé pour les maires en
particulier soit pour les très
prématurés voire même des mamans qui ont
besoin d'hébergement avant la grossesse
ils ne disposent pas d'hébergement et
donc on prône quand même la mise en
oeuvre de d'hébergement à proximité
c'est particulièrement le cas et ça ne
vous est en a pas en Guyane bien
évidemment mais aussi à Saint-Barthélémy
enfin ce qu'on peut dire également c'est
que il existe des dispositifs plutôt
entre guillemets contraignants ou
incitant on pense notamment aux mesures
judiciaires d'aide éducative ou même
d'aide à la gestion des budgets
familiaux qui pourraient être déployés
sur nos territoires le recours de ces
mesures doit être inscrit de notre point
de vue dans les schémas d'appartementaux
et ça n'est pas le cas nous semble-t-il
jusqu'ici
pour terminer sur les acteurs de la
politique de soutien à parentalité on a
deux sujets majeurs premièrement il
manque un chef de fil ce qu'on voit
c'est que les caisses d'allocations
familiales sont reconnues sur chacun des
territoires comme des acteurs majeurs
mais le rôle n'est pas affirmé notamment
dans les documents cadres qui existent
et dans la mesure où la prochaine
convention de gestion et d'objectifs la
cause est en cours de signature avec
l'État pour 2023 2027 c'est peut-être
l'occasion de dire quand notre mère les
cafés sont le chef de fil affirmé et
assumer pleinement puisque c'est un rôle
qu'ils assume déjà pour faire en sorte
que le soutien à parentalité puisse
bénéficier d'un axe à part entière dans
cette convention d'objectif et de moyens
2023 2027 le deuxième sujet de la
gouvernance c'est que c'est très lourd
et on prône quand même dans le rapport
le déploiement et le renforcement du
moyen de pilotage et de coordination de
l'animation des réseaux et puis on se
rend compte aussi qu'il faut quand même
alléger les dispositifs existants on a
des comités départementaux de 41 membres
ne serait-ce que pour simplement les
convoquer si vous voulez c'est un
exercice un exercice de à part entière
et il nous semble-t-il qu'on est là dans
ce que la France c'est faire le mieux en
matière administrative c'est-à-dire des
comités des terroriques et qui
mériteraient vraisemblablement d'être
réduit à leur potion la plus efficace
nous semble-t-il c'est la
recommandations numéro 20 et la
troisième enfin c'est renforcé le rôle
des acteurs de proximité là je parle des
associations bien évidemment on a deux
sujets sur le volet associatifs que nous
avons identifié dans le rapport un sur
les financements on se rend compte qu'il
y a beaucoup d'appels à projets et que
les associations nous le disent
également elles sont hyper sollicitées
pour répondre systématiquement ces
appels à projets elles ne dispose pas de
financement pérenne et pluriannuels ce
qui fait qu'en réalité c'est du coup par
coup elles sont remises en question
chaque année et à chaque appel à projet
ce qui rend l'exercice de manière très
très inconfortable et les CAF ont
commencé d'ailleurs à réorienter un
petit peu leur financement pour
commencer à stabiliser les acteurs
locaux parce que le mariage territorial
s'appuie avant tout sur les acteurs
associatifs aux côtés des acteurs
institutionnels et en matière de
financement le sujet qui a été pointé
c'est évidemment les CAF peuvent
intervenir qu'à 80% de des projets et
donc il y a une quote de 20% qui
revient collectivité qui pour la plupart
sont dans le rouge et qui pour la
plupart ont du mal à mobiliser même les
20% qui sont à leur charge et donc on
pose la question de savoir s'il n'y a
pas intérêt on outre-mer sur ces
territoires ou les collectivités sont
défaillantes pour des raisons
budgétaires de permettre aux caves de
pouvoir financer 100% de ces programmes
pour leur permettre une efficacité
indépoiement effective sur les
territoires et enfin pour les
associations c'est la montée en
compétences de ceux qui sont à leur tête
et qui sont sur le terrain donc les
opérationnels le montage de projet comme
je l'ai dit au travers des appels à
projets sont de plus en plus complexes
les acteurs du terrain ne sont pas
forcément tous calibrés et épauler
techniquement pour pouvoir répondre à
ces appels à projets et nous sommes
importants de pouvoir apporter cette
expertise peut-être d'encourager des
fédérations nationales à venir
s'implanter en outre-mer pour que les
associations locales puissent s'adosser
à une expertise reconnue évidemment je
parle pas de la Croix-Rouge et du NAF
qui sont déjà implantés mais il y a
d'autres fédérations qui pourraient
mettre le souhait de s'implanter avec
peut-être des appels à projets pilotés
par le ministère d'outre-mer pourquoi
pas en interministériel mais avec un
leader chef de filtre avec aux côtés des
cafs leur implication de notre point de
vue pourrait être un levier intéressant
pour nos associations puisque ça les
conforterait dans le rôle d'ingénierie
dont un ne dispose pas suffisamment
peut-être aujourd'hui voilà j'en ai
terminé c'était la 19ème recommandation
et si vous le voulez maintenant on peut
passer au jeu des questions réponses
avec les trois autres rapports
pour celui ou celle qui veut commencer
je pense qu'on va vous donner un micro
pour que ceux qui nous suivent puissent
profiter également de la question poser
Emmanuel GIR pour le réseau outre-mer de
France Télévisions je voulais savoir si
famille monoparentale situation précaire
grossesse précoce avec la spécificité de
Mayotte et de la Guyane est-ce que vous
qualifierez la famille de d'outre-mer
comme d'une structure défaillante non
pas du tout le regard que les
délégations ont porté c'était un regard
anthropologique et sociologique sur une
réalité que l'administration française
peut être méconnée aujourd'hui et ce que
nous disons c'est que si nous voulons
que les politiques familiales et
parentales soient efficaces dans nos
territoires nous devons tenir compte
d'une réalité territoriale est-ce que
vous dites là en fait c'est pas un
jugement de valeur que nous avons porté
c'est une objectivation des situations
pour que la puissance publique puisse y
apporter des réponses aujourd'hui les
modèles quels qu'ils soient dans nos
territoires se respectent tous et loin
de la volonté des rapporteurs des
délégations de porter un jugement bien
au contraire ce qu'on veut nous c'est
que nos moyens de la puissance publique
soit mise à contribution pour aider ces
modèles à évoluer au regard des grands
bouleversements que nous connaissons ne
serait-ce qu'au titre au titre
migratoire
de reconnaître ce qui est défaillant
aujourd'hui ce sont les inégalités qui
existent encore et l'ensemble de nos
interlocuteurs l'ont souligné
sur les différents territoires par
exemple il est anormal injuste et il
faut le dénoncer que un enfant porte de
handicap à Mayotte ne puisse pas
bénéficier des mêmes droits de la hache
que n'importe quel enfant
de France
il faut aussi le dire
on va se succéder je pense avec les
quatre apports bah oui ce sera plus
simple c'est pas monopoliser la parole
pour les réponses aux questions puisque
c'est un rapport co-écrit
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres questions
on est quatre à pouvoir répondre donc là
non mais globalement ce qui est ce qui
est important de dire c'est que oui il y
a des particularités dans les
territoires d'outre-mer mais c'est
l'histoire donc nous ne sommes pas là il
a très président Artano a très bien
répondu il y a des réalités il faut
comprendre pourquoi il y a une série
elle était c'est parfois l'histoire
c'est parfois aussi une méconnaissance
finalement où une méconnaissance des
droits qui fait que
même sans une grossesse précoce on peut
réussir à accéder à des droits à la fois
sociaux
familiaux et donc c'est pas juste une
grossesse précoce or ça nous a été dit
dans certains territoires pour pouvoir
accéder à un statut et sortir de la
précarité connue déjà dans la famille
donc il faut éviter de reproduire ces
cette précarité cette vulnérabilité
parce que éduquer un enfant et on en
discutait tout à l'heure lors de la
réunion de la délégation pour c'est un
tout à la fois des parents ou un parent
c'est un logement c'est une éducation
c'est la langue c'est beaucoup de choses
c'est l'électronisme ou le des parents
qui peut être un frein aussi donc il y a
tout un écosystème comprendre
l'écosystème et apporter des réponses
sans vouloir forcément dupliquer bon je
crois que c'est important aussi de se
dire on va différencier les réponses
parce que chaque territoire a des
particularités lorsque vous êtes dans
aux Antilles et bien pour un coucher par
exemple le parcours d'un accouchement en
fonction de l'île où vous trouvez c'est
déjà
des particularités très très prégnantes
et donc des réponses à apporter parce
qu'on peut pas laisser les femmes sans
solution lorsque vous êtes à une
île qui n'est pas ni la Guadeloupe ni
pardon à Marie-Galante bien sûr à
Marie-Galante ni la Guadeloupe ni la
Martinique il faut apporter des
solutions pour que le parcours
de l'enfant dès sa naissance ne soit pas
un parcours du combattant pour la mère
par exemple oui monsieur il est là le
micro
les solutions qui étaient apportées d'un
point de vue historique par la notion de
famille élargie et vous avez dit que
avec la modernité entre guillemets c'est
c'est soutiens qu'on pouvait avait
tendance à diminuer ce que vous pouvez
un peu développer là-dessus pourquoi
cette cette solution on va dire que la
nature a trouvé pourquoi le temps a
disparaître et elle se court-circuite
avec quoi en fait
je crois que pour avoir travaillé nous
avons travaillé tous ensemble mais en
fait c'est en matière d'aménagement du
territoire déjà et puis la façon
d'habiter à changer dans beaucoup de nos
territoires et bien il y a plusieurs
générations habitaient les unes à côté
des autres et quelquefois dans une même
maison maintenant avec l'évolution et
bien il y a des personnes qui ont des
logements et particulièrement les
logements sur ceux qui sont proposés
dans différentes communes et bien ce
sont des immeubles dans des bars et la
façon d'habiter à changer et là la
particularité de certaines de nos
territoires c'est de permettre justement
avec cette intergénérationnalité on
avait effectivement
des parents des grands-parents et
quelques fois de générations au même
trois qui étaient à proximité donc tout
le monde contribuait à l'éducation des
enfants aujourd'hui on a de moins en
moins cette façon de faire et là il y a
des parents
nucléaires qui sont en difficulté parce
que le mode de garde on n'a pas
forcément sur l'ensemble du territoire
et l'ensemble de nos territoires les
modes de garde approprié pour élever les
enfants donc ça c'est aussi des frais
qui ne permettent pas forcément aux
femmes particulièrement parce qu'on a
beaucoup de familles monoparentales et
bien de se former ou d'aller vers les
services publics qui sont disponibles
quand ils sont disponibles donc là notre
rapport permet de mettre en évidence les
difficultés parce que dans les
politiques publiques adaptables à nos
territoires il existe beaucoup beaucoup
de possibilités par contre on ne peut
pas forcément les retrouver sur chaque
territoire de la même façon
en Guadeloupe par exemple c'est une
archipel à Saint-Martin c'est différent
quand c'est Barthélemy donc là
effectivement certains accès certaines
possibilités de droit et madame la
Présidente parlait des problèmes liés
aussi à l'électronisme et à
l'illettrisme et nous avons également
des freins qui sont liés aussi aux
langues parce que beaucoup de beaucoup
de nos territoires il y a pas que des
personnes qui sont qui ont des langues
maternelles françaises ou même créole il
y a beaucoup d'autres qui sont
anglophones hispanophones enfin il y a
une diversité de situation qui font
aussi que qu'il y ait des fins et là
nous sommes au Sénat la chambre des
territoires et là je félicite leur ce
rapport parce que là vous voyez qu'il y
a une diversité de d'origine de nos
différents rapporteurs mais nous sommes
là pour représenter les territoires et
pour mettre en évidence les frais qui
nous permet pas toujours d'avoir reçu
chacun des territoires de la nation les
mêmes doigts et les mêmes réponses
surtout donc là c'est important et ce
que vient de dire ma collègue Nassima
DEDA de la Réunion mais qui a été très
assidûment présente lors de nos travaux
et bien chacun des territoires il y a
des particularités et l'objet du rapport
c'est de permettre que nous puissions
trouver les meilleures réponses
possibles pour répondre au mieux aux
besoins de chaque des territoire et de
chacune des personnes donc il y a le
problème qui a été évoqué par le
président également le problème
concernant les lois mais aussi des pères
dans notre rapport dans son axe il
parlait également de la reconnaissance
et ça a été dit également par Elsa Shark
alors il y a aujourd'hui une volonté du
gouvernement le 1er juin dernier le
gouvernement proposait qu'il y ait une
attention toute particulière pour la
mise en oeuvre d'un service de public de
service public pardon de petites enfance
alors nous attendons beaucoup de de cet
outil là pour nous permettre justement
de mettre en adéquation nos différents
recommandations avec cette volonté
politique affichée du gouvernement donc
j'espère qu'il y aura des suites
favorables et c'est une note un de nos
soins également merci
je voulais reprendre non
choisissant pas trop la Guadeloupe mais
je pense surtout à Saint-Martin et à
Saint-Barthélemy vous avez pas eu le
sentiment quand même de vous approcher
on va dire d'un profil de population
assez atypique par rapport au reste de
l'outre-mer compte tenu du statut de
Saint-Martin qui est à la fois
hollandais et français et compte tenu de
Saint-Barthélémy qui est réputé comme
étant l'île enfin une île avec une
activité touristique
bien particulière
alors
Saint-Martin c'est vrai que nous avons
passé une journée à Saint-Martin avec
Elsa et victoire
on a constaté véritablement que ça
Martin cumule toutes les difficultés à
la fois d'illettrisme d'électronisme
avec la multiplication aussi de langue
parlée il y a sans nationalité plus de
100 nationalité avec des parcours de
grossesse compliqué et puis des
événements climatiques qui ont fait que
le logement aussi est un vrai problème
donc c'est pour ça que dans ce rapport
on se dit aussi on le dit il faut des
réponses adaptées c'est-à-dire qu'on
différencie par contre ce sont des
territoires français donc l'objectif
c'est de faire monter en compétences
faire monter réduire l'électronisme
réduire réduire l'illettrisme parce que
l'objectif c'est forcément de donner la
même éducation
de la République elle est une et
indivisible elle doit l'être aussi dans
nos territoires ultramarins c'est-à-dire
que les valeurs partagées de la
République on doit les retrouver dans
nos territoires c'est pour ça qu'on a
pas proposé de par exemple de de
traduire dans toutes les langues des
outils non il faut plutôt prendre le
problème à l'envers c'est-à-dire qu'il
faut donner l'éducation donner la
formation et donner aussi envie à des
gens avec des compétences et ça c'est
une difficulté aussi des dans les
territoires ultramarins donnés aux gens
aux personnes qui ont des compétences
l'envie de rester dans leur territoire
dans dans ces territoires ou de faire
venir des compétences et ça c'est une
difficulté aussi
si on a d'autres qui veulent compléter
et il y a des peut-être des questions
parce que on remercie ceux qui sont en
visio également
est-ce qu'il y a des questions vous
monsieur pardon
j'ai raté le tout début peut-être que
vous avez déjà répondu à cette question
[Rires]
mais j'avais quand même une question sur
enfin on voit qu'il y a des mesures qui
sont très diverses qui abordent plein de
thématiques différentes
quelle traduction vous allez en faire
d'un point de vue politique
comment on peut le faire peser dans
voilà dans quel calendrier etc alors
j'ai peut-être laissé les achats
répondre mais vous aurez compris
peut-être avec l'actualité que nous
sommes nous sommes à la fin d'une
session donc la traduction législative
va pas être immédiate oui merci pour
pour cette question c'est effectivement
un sujet qui est très transverse on voit
bien que les différents sujets qui ont
été en fait abordés sont multiples et
variés mais on voit aussi à quel point
la parentalité est au cœur finalement en
fait de notre société à quel point en
fait c'est essentiel dans la
transmission des valeurs mais également
en fait du savoir des valeurs de
l'éducation et nous voyons en fait à
travers les 20 recommandations que nous
faisons que c'est à la fois en fait sur
le constat mais je pense que c'est
nécessaire d'avoir justement un constat
sur la parentalité dans dans les
territoires d'outre-mer et après de voir
en fait à la fois le volet aide et
accompagnement comme celle a été
détaillée mais également la coordination
des acteurs puisque là aussi on a pu
pointer à la fois une faiblesse ou par
moment en fait une défaillance donc avec
différents leviers on voit également en
fait sur le plan qui n'est pas des
moindres des 1000 premiers jours sur la
question notamment de la petite enfance
que cela peut prendre une traduction en
fait très simple et d'avoir justement de
par les annonces en fait
gouvernementales une traduction très
concrète et effectivement dans les
textes qui seront amenés peut-être à
venir ou en tout cas qu'on pourra en
fait initier à partir de la prochaine
rentrée législative
et peut-être rappeler si je peux me
permettre que les quatre rapporteurs ont
eu la chance d'avoir un échange avec la
secrétaire d'État à l'enfance
voilà c'est un élément de voilà
justement pour commencer à échanger sur
les perspectives avant même l'adoption
du rapport donc avec toute la prudence
qui s'imposait au rapporteur puisque les
délégation ne s'était pas encore
prononcé ce qui démontre un intérêt du
gouvernement et de effectivement on
l'espère bien évidemment comme l'a dit
elsahark une traduction qui peut être
législative réglementaire et peut-être
parfois opérationnel voire même sur le
terrain sur les bonnes pratiques en tout
n'est pas du domaine législatif mais
était important pour nous de dresser ce
panorama pour justement identifier les
acteurs en charge
peut-être aussi se dire que lorsqu'on
parle de différenciation
finalement la différenciation elle peut
être
utile aussi à l'Hexagone c'est-à-dire
qu'on a fléché des choses particulières
mais ça peut amener aussi des bonnes
pratiques ou des solutions
adaptées au territoire en fonction des
besoins
les sénateurs sont les spécialistes de
la différenciation mais sont les grandes
défenseurs aussi des valeurs
républicaines
partager
bon ben je pense qu'on a épuisé non pas
les personnes que nous avions invité
mais on a épuisé les questions moi je
tiens à vous remercier pour cette
participation à ce point presse vous
avez dans le dossier presse le rapport
bien entendu l'essentiel et les
rapporteurs si vous souhaitez les
interroger à l'issue de cette cette
présentation sont à votre disposition
alors merci à vous et bel été chaud donc
le on espère que le monsieur qui a eu la
tête
va mieux
qu'il n'aura pas une un gros bleu sur la
tête ça va vous allez garder tous les
neurones bon alors c'est bon
désolé mais ça du ça doit faire très mal
quand même non oui bon bah écoutez merci
à tous je souhaite un bel été et
j'espère qu'il y en a qui auront la
chance de visiter nos beaux territoires
ultramarins pendant cette période
estivale aussi voilà
merci merci